Speaker 1: We are going to take some calls. We are
going to take calls via Discord, as we often do.
You can find the discord at David Pakman dot
com slash discord. Let's talk to some people
starting here with Alex from
Baltimore. Alex, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, can you hear me? Yes,
I can. All right. First, I want to say I do
thank my lucky stars every day that are not David
Pakman. Thank you. Of course, that's a predator
right there. Yes. Yes, you are getting again.
OK, so what are the better faith arguments I hear
from your average Joe and Jane against progressive
policies would be not ideological so much as.
The American government and the bureaucracy within
is just so bloated, slow, wasteful, expensive that
we don't even want to take the chance
to give them up bigger a bigger program,
more responsibility because they're just going
to screw it up and cost us a ridiculous amount
of money and it's going to be terrible. As
someone who wants those policies implemented,
is there truth to that? And how would you
approach dealing with that if it is true?
Speaker 1: So I think it's hard to deal in
generalities. It's a very popular talking point
just to say the government's incompetence. Don't
give the government more stuff to do. The very,
very. Sounds very tight, neat and tidy
as a talking point. The reality is that
many of the proposals from the left would
actually simplify the bureaucratic aspect
of it. For example, there are proposals, as some
say, to eliminate a whole bunch of small means
tested social welfare programs and put in place
one program with either only one bureaucracy for
means testing or no means testing at all. That's
a dramatic simplification, and you're actually
making it more likely that government will succeed
because it's a much simpler program. So no one,
a lot of times you're not really giving government
more stuff to do. And the number two in terms of
the bloat argument. Many of the people advocating
for government to start doing certain things are
also saying government should stop doing certain
things. So where is they want to grow one area?
They're saying shrink another. And
so that argument sounds appealing,
but it's quite literally untrue in many cases.
Speaker 3: Yeah, no, I get that and I'm that's
just more of me debating with people. Sure. But
sometimes I do kind of agree with them in certain
things. A good example, like infrastructure and
high speed rail. In particular, you hear stories
that, oh, they shut it down in California because
it was costing twenty five million dollars a mile.
Meanwhile, France, who is quite progressive
for the most part and has lots of unions,
can do it for $9 million a mile. Yeah.
Speaker 1: And I mean, what you've got
to remember, it was in general, Europe is much
better at trains than the United States. So when
you're better at something, you're usually
going to do it more cheaply. And number two,
the government isn't building the rail, they're
hiring people to do it. So at the end of the day,
it's actually private industry that needs to get
better. So listen, it's very loud where you are.
So I'm going to let you go. I'm curious, what are
you doing? Are you running a lathe or something?
Speaker 3: No, I work at a weld
shop. I'm a pipefitters. OK, you're
Speaker 1: fitting pipe during the call.
Speaker 3: I well, no, I stepped outside. Oh,
OK. Breezy inches away from dog.
Speaker 1: Oh, I see the pipe
fitting would have been even louder.
Speaker 3: Well, yeah, there's lots of welding,
even more motors and then clanking branches,
though it would have been worse. All right.
Speaker 1: I appreciate it. I appreciate it.
Speaker 3: Thank you for the call. Nice.
Speaker 1: Save it. Take a nap! Alex stepped out
of the pipe fitting area. Very, very important.